SEAN HANNITY COME ALIVE.
>> Sean: TUCKER, THANK YOU.
WELCOME TO HANNITY.
WE START TONIGHT WITH A FOX NEWS
ALERT.
FOUR MAJOR BREAKING STORIES THAT
WE ARE COVERING.
NONE OF THIS IS GREAT FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, THE
DEEP STATE, OR THE MOB MEDIA.
I GUARANTEE YOU THAT THIS WAS
LEAKED ON PURPOSE TO GET AHEAD
OF WHAT IS COMING.
THAT IS A HUGE CRISIS, BECAUSE
BREAKING JUST MOMENTS AGO,
ANOTHER BLOW TO THE DEMOCRAT'S
IMPEACHMENT TRADE.
THERE IS A REPORT AT THIS HOUR
THAT AN FBI OFFICIAL IS NOW
UNDER CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION FOR
ALTERING A DOCUMENT RELATED TO
THE 2016 SURVEILLANCE OF THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN ADVISOR,
CARTER PAGE.
NOW, REMEMBER, THE FISA WARRANTS
AGAINST THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN,
REMEMBER, THAT WAS THE BACK DOOR
TO GET EVERYTHING INTO ALL
THINGS.
NOW, THESE REPORTS BEARING OUT.
THAT WOULD BE CALLED THE FISA
ABUSE, EXACTLY WHAT WE HAVE BEEN
EXPOSING ON THE SHOW FOR A VERY,
VERY LONG TIME.
AND NOW, FINALLY AFTER YEARS OF
WAITING, THANKS TO THE PROBE NOW
AT AN END, JUSTICE IS ABOUT TO
BE SERVED.
CLEARLY, THIS IS BEING LEAKED IN
ADVANCE TO TRY TO GET AHEAD OF
THE REPORT THAT LINDSEY GRAHAM
CONFIRMED TO US LAST NIGHT,
RIGHT HERE ON THIS PROGRAM.
THE PFIZER REPORT WILL COME OUT
ON DECEMBER 9TH.
HE WILL TESTIFY BEFORE THE
SENATE ON DECEMBER 11TH.
WE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
MONITOR.
THROUGHOUT THE HOUR, SARA CARTER
WILL BREAK MORE NEWS ON THIS IN
A MINUTE.
WE ARE ALSO TRACKING FOR OTHER
STORIES.
GET THIS.
ANOTHER DISASTROUS DAY FOR THE
SCHIFF COUP ATTEMPTS.
IT WAS EVEN WORSE, BELIEVE IT OR
NOT, THAN YESTERDAY.
NO INFORMATION SURROUNDING THE
BIDENS THANKS TO A LOT OF HER
LINDSEY GRAHAM.
WE HAVE THAT LETTER.
WE ALSO HAVE A VIDEO.
YOU ARE GOING TO WANT TO HIT
YOUR RECORD BUTTON TONIGHT AND
LOOK AT THIS FOR DECADES TO
COME.
FIRST, WE START AT THE
WASHINGTON SWAMP.
MORE HEARSAY, MORE OPINION, AND
MORE ARROGANT DEMOCRATS.
ARE YOU READY FOR THIS?
IT WAS NOT ON SPEAKER,
CONTRADICTING THE PERSON THAT
WAS ACTUALLY ON THE PRIVATE CALL
AND THE PERSON WHO WAS ON THE
OTHER END OF THE TABLE.
THIS IS HOW BAD THIS SHOW HAS
NOW BECOME.
SO BAD, HE EVEN PRESENTED A
FACT-WITNESSED TODAY WITH ZERO
FAX.
NONE WHATSOEVER.
THIS WAS THE SCHIFF'S GRAND
FINALE.
IT WAS SUPPOSED TO TIE
EVERYTHING TOGETHER.
INSTEAD, AGAIN, THIS BLEW UP
RIGHT IN SCHIFF'S FACE AND THE
DEMOCRAT'S FACE.
IT WAS THE PERFECT SUMMARY OF
THE NONCASE OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> JULY 19, HE TOLD HIM ABOUT
THE UPCOMING ZELENSKY CALL.
JULY 20TH, HE TOLD HIM --
AUGUST 16TH, HE TELLS TAYLOR
WHAT HE TOLD VOLKER.
HE TALKS TO TAYLOR.
AUGUST 22ND, MORRISON TALKS TO
TAYLOR.
SEPTEMBER 4TH, MORRISON TELLS
TAYLOR ABOUT --
MORRISON TELLS TAYLOR WHAT HE
TELLS TRUMP.
SEPTEMBER 8TH, HE TELLS HIM WHAT
HE TOLD --
>> Sean: YOU FOLLOW THAT?
THAT IS THE DEMOCRAT'S CASE IN A
NUTSHELL.
THAT IS SUPPOSED TO BE THERE
COMPELLING OUT EVIDENCE.
THAT IS WHY THEY WANT TO HURT
THIS COUNTRY, BRING THIS COUNTRY
TO THE BRINK OF IMPEACHMENT,
BECAUSE THEY NEVER GOT OVER THE
FACT THAT DONALD TRUMP WON THE
ELECTION.
THEY NEVER SAW IT COMING.
THE TWO WITNESSES TODAY, AUDITOR
TRAIN WRECKS.
ONE, EIGHT DIPLOMATS, NAMED
DAVID HOLMES.
YEP SHE CLAIMED, THIS IS NOT,
I'M NOT MAKING THIS UP.
HE OVERHEARD PRESIDENT TRUMP ON
A PHONE CALL TALK ABOUT AN
INVESTIGATION.
ON THE OTHER END OF THE PHONE
CALL WAS AMBASSADOR SONDLAND.
HE WAS SITTING ACROSS THE TABLE
FROM SANS LENS AT
FROM SONS LENS AT
FROM SONDLLENS AT
FROM SONDLANNS AT
FROM SONDLAND. AT
HOLMES DID NOT HEAR THE
CONVERSATION.
HIS TESTIMONY CONTRADICTS WHAT
THE GUY ACTUALLY ON THE CALL
SAID.
THAT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
YESTERDAY'S STAR WITNESS, GORDON
SONLAND.
THAT'S WHAT THE SCHIFF SHOW IS
NOW REDUCED TO.
ZERO.
I MEAN ZERO RELEVANT FACTS.
IT WASN'T EVEN TOTALLY CLEAR WHY
SHE WAS THERE.
IN THE OPENING STATEMENT,
FALSELY ACCUSED REPUBLICANS OF
IGNORING RUSSIA MET ALENE AND
ALSO FALSELY ACCUSED REPUBLICANS
OF PUSHING A CONSPIRACY THEORY
ABOUT UKRAINIAN ELECTION
INTERFERENCE.
WILL SOMEBODY PLEASE GIVE HER
THE JANUARY 11, 2017 REPORT AT
POLITICO.COM ABOUT UKRAINIAN
ELECTION INTERFERENCE?
UKRAINE DID IN FACT INTERFERE IN
THE 2016 ELECTIONS TO HELP
HILLARY CLINTON HURT
DONALD TRUMP.
THANKFULLY, IN A POWERFUL
MOMENT, WELL, THIS WAS REALLY
POWERFUL.
CONGRESSMAN SET THE RECORD
STRAIGHT.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
>> YOU KNOW, IN 1998, I
VOLUNTARILY JOINED THE
UNITED STATES ARMY RESERVE,
BECAUSE I SAW OUR COUNTRY UNDER
ATTACK TIME AND TIME AGAIN.
BILL CLINTON WAS THE PRESIDENT.
I DIDN'T VOTE FOR BILL CLINTON,
BUT HE WAS MY COMMANDER IN
CHIEF.
I'M GRATEFUL TO LIVE IN A
COUNTRY THAT GETS TO
LEGITIMATELY ELECT OUR LEADERS.
I'VE BEEN TO PLACES WHERE PEOPLE
DON'T GET TO AND IT'S NOT PRETT
PRETTY.
DR. HILL, I'M SORRY.
I HAVE TO SAY THIS.
YOU SAID BASED ON STATEMENTS
THAT SOME IN THIS COMMITTEE DO
NOT BELIEVE THAT RUSSIA --
THAT'S MR. SCHIFF'S NARRATIVE.
THAT'S WHERE YOU HEARD IT.
WE DID A WHOLE REPORT ON IT.
WE AGREE THAT RUSSIA HAS DONE
THIS SINCE THE SOVIET UNION AND
THEY'VE ACTUALLY GOTTEN BETTER
AT IT.
THAT'S A PROBLEM.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, CERTAIN
UKRAINIANS DID WORK AGAINST
CANDIDATE TRUMP.
SOME, WITH THE DNC.
IF THAT'S DEBUNKED, WHY IS IT
THAT MR. SCHIFF HAS DENIED
ALEXANDER TO LUPA FROM
TESTIFYING TO COME FOR DOMINIC
FORWARD AND DEBUNK IT?
>> Sean: SHE WAS THE DNC
OPERATIVE.
SHE WENT THERE TO COLLUDE, TO
DIG UP DIRT FOR HILLARY CLINTON
AND SMEAR DONALD TRUMP AND
MEMBERS OF HIS CAMPAIGN.
THAT WOULD BE CALLED IN MY MIND
COLLUSION.
BUT TODAY'S WITNESS, A SO-CALLED
UKRAINE EXPERT KNEW NOTHING
ABOUT IT.
REPORTER, CHERYL ATKINSON,
FORMERLY OF CBS NEWS, POINTED
OUT, THE IDEA THAT SOME OF OUR
TOP EXPERTS ON UKRAINE ARE
CLOSE-MINDED TO THIS INFORMATION
AND AT LEAST ONE SAID HE WAS
ENTIRELY UNAWARE OF IT, BUT WE
ARE MAKING IMPORTANT DECISIONS,
COULD BE CONSIDERED DISTURBING.
YEAH.
YOU THINK?
THIS WAS PROBABLY THE BIGGEST
REVELATION OUT OF THE HEARINGS.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND WITHOUT A
DOUBT, THOUGH SCHIFF IS A GIANT
FAILURE DUD, BUT DON'T TAKE MY
WORD FOR IT.
JUST LISTEN TO FORMER
INDEPENDENT COUNSEL, KEN STARR.
HE THOUGHT YESTERDAY, OH, THIS
IS GOING TO BE REALLY A BAD DAY
FOR THE REPUBLICANS AND FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HE IS NOW CHANGED HIS MIND.
>> WE ARE NOT ON TRIAL.
WE ARE IN A FACT GATHERING MODE,
BUT WHAT ARE WE GATHERING FACTS
ABOUT?
WAS THERE A CRIME, AND THEN
LET'S WEIGH THIS GRAVITY AND
SERIOUSNESS OF THAT CRIME.
IT DOESN'T REACH THE LEVEL OF
TREASON, BRIBERY, OR OTHER HIGH
CRIMES AND MISDEMEANORS?
MY ASSESSMENT OF THE EVIDENCE
THUS FAR, NOWHERE CLOSE.
THE EVIDENCE IS CONFLICTING AND
AMBIGUOUS.
>> Sean: CONFLICTING,
AMBIGUOUS, NOWHERE CLOSE.
THIS IS AN ABSOLUTE ON MAKE IT
UNMITIGATED --
HE KNOWS THAT THIS IS A DISASTER
AND HE SHOWED HIS ANGER.
REPUBLICANS DEFEATED THE SCHIFF
SO BADLY, THE CHARLIE DANIELS
SONG GOES AND THE DEVIL WENT ON
TO GEORGIA.
HE KNEW HE'D BEEN BEAT.
HE LAID THAT GOLDEN FIDDLE DOWN
AT DONALD TRUMP'S FEET, I GUESS,
IN THIS CASE.
BEFORE WE SHOW YOU THIS, YOU
HAVE TO REMEMBER, THIS IS THE
GUY, THE ONLY PERSON ON TAPE
EVER CAUGHT COLLUDING WITH
SOMEBODY THAT HE THINKS IS A
RUSSIAN TO GET COMPROMISING
MATERIALS ON DONALD TRUMP.
THIS ISN'T THE FIRST TIME THIS
GUY GOT CAUGHT LYING IN, LIKE HE
LIED ABOUT, OH, I HAVE NO IDEA
WHO THE WHISTLE-BLOWER'S.
WELL, I SHOULD HAVE BEEN HONEST
ABOUT IT, BUT NOW I DON'T KNOW
ABOUT IT.
BY THE WAY, ONE OF MY FAVORITE
TYPES OF ALL TIME ALL-TIME,
ACCUSING DONALD TRUMP OF WHAT HE
WAS GUILTY OF.
COMP RISING MATERIALS.
LISTEN.
SPEAK OF THE DAY AFTER BOB
TESTIFIED THAT DONALD TRUMP
INVITED INTERFERENCE, HEY
RUSSIA, IF YOU ARE LISTENING,
COME GET HILLARY'S EMAILS.
FOR GOOD YOU HAVE SOMETHING THAT
YOU CAN'T REVEAL QUESTION MEXICO
I CAN'T REVEAL THAT.
>> WE HAVE NOT SPOKEN DIRECTLY
WITH THE WHISTLE-BLOWER.
TYPICAL DONALD TRUMP IS BACK ON
THE PHONE, ASKING ANOTHER NATION
TO INVOLVE ITSELF IN ANOTHER
U.S. ELECTION.
>> WHAT'S THE NATURE OF THE
COMPROMISE?
>>
PUTIN WAS MADE AWARE OF THE
AVAILABILITY OF THE COMPROMISING
MATERIAL?
>> YES, OF COURSE.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE WILL BE BACK IN TOUCH.
>> YOU SHOULDN'T RELY ON WHAT
THE PRESIDENT SAID IN THE CALL
RECORD.
>> I'M GOING TO SAY THIS
ONLY 7 TIMES, SO YOU BETTER
LISTEN GOOD.
I WANT YOU TO MAKE UP DIRT ON MY
POLITICAL OPPONENT.
>> Sean: COMPROMISE, CORRUPT,
CONGENITAL LIAR.
HE'S LIED TO THE COUNTRY FOR
THREE YEARS.
THREE LONG YEARS.
HE SHOWED HIS RAGE.
NOW, I'M SURE IF IT WAS UP TO
HIM, HE JUST WOULD TRY TO BRING
IN MORE HEARSAY WITNESSES,
OPINION WITNESSES FOR ADDITIONS
FIRST, DEPOSITIONS, AND THEN
HEARINGS.
BUT I THINK PELOSI PROBABLY
WON'T LET HIM.
SHE DIDN'T WANT TO THE SHOW TO
BEGIN WITH AND IT'S BEEN PRETTY
CLEAR OUR PRIORITY IS TO GET THE
OUT OF HERE AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE, THROW IT TO THE SENATE
AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
SHE CAN REMAIN SPEAKER IN NAME
ONLY.
IF DEMOCRATS WANT A VOTE BEFORE
CHRISTMAS, THAT DOESN'T LEAVE
THE COMPROMISE, SCHIFF MUCH MORE
TIME TO DO MORE INVESTIGATING.
IF I HAD TO MAKE A PREDICTION
TONIGHT, I'D SAY THAT SCHIFF
ADMITS DEFEAT AND SENDS THIS
WHOLE FLAMING BAG OF DOG AROUND
THINGS GIVING WE CAN.
GOOD LUCK TURNING THAT GARBAGE
INTO SOMETHING USABLE,
JERRY NADLER.
ON A SIZABLE NOTE, LOOK AT THIS.
I CAN'T BELIEVE IT.
IT MIGHT HAVE BEEN COOKED UP
DURING HIS CASE OF UKRAINE
FUND-RAISER.
THAT'S RIGHT.
THE COMPROMISE, CONGENITAL LIAR,
YEAH.
HE HAD A FUND-RAISER WITH THE
UKRAINIAN BUSINESSMAN.
YOU CAN'T MAKE THAT UP.
THE MOB AND THE MEDIA ARE
DESPERATE.
THESE PEOPLE ARE THE SAME
PEOPLE, SAME LIARS, SAME
CONSPIRACY THEORISTS, SAME HOPE
SPREADERS, IF YOU WILL.
THEY'VE BEEN LYING TO WE THE
PEOPLE NOW FOR THREE PLUS YEARS.
ONE HOAX AFTER ANOTHER, ONE
CONSPIRACY THEORY AFTER ANOTHER.
RUSSIA, RUSSIA, RUSSIA.
IMPEACH, IMPEACH, IMPEACH.
PREDICTING THIS IS THE
PRESIDENT'S DEMISE.
THAT IS THE PRESIDENT'S DEMISE.
THAT IS A GAME CHANGER.
BREATHLESSLY, DRAMATICALLY
CRYING FOR 3-4 YEARS.
YOU MAY WANT TO HIT THE RECORD
BUTTON NOW, BECAUSE YOU ARE
GOING TO WANT TO SHOW THIS TO
YOUR FRIENDS.
3-2-1-GO.
>> I HAVE NOT SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
THIS SINCE OCTOBER 20TH, 1973,
WHEN PRESIDENT NIXON FIRED --
>> RICHARD NIXON.
>> ECHOES OF WATERGATE.
>> A GIANT STEP TOWARDS
WATERGATE.
>> IMPEACHMENT IMPLICATIONS ARE
NOW IN THE AIR.
SPEAK OF THE PRESIDENT BE
REMOVED FROM OFFICE.
PICK A BOMBSHELL.
>> BOMBSHELL.
>> BOMBSHELL STORIES DROPPING
SEEMINGLY EVERY DAY.
>> HE WILL RESIGN THE
PRESIDENCY.
HE IS WARMING UP TO THE IDEA OF
HIS RECORD DOMINIC RESIGNATION.
>> HE IS LASHING UP HERE IT'S
BIGGER HE FEELS THE WALLS
CLOSING IN.
>> CLOSING IN.
>> YOU CAN FEEL THE THREAD BEING
PULLED.
YOU CAN FEEL THE CALL START TO
COME OFF THE EMPEROR.
I BELIEVE THIS IS THE BEGINNING
OF THE END.
>> DONALD TRUMP IS A DONE.
HE'S DONE.
THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT THAT.
>> Sean: 2016 ALL THROUGH THE
ELECTIONS.
ALL THROUGH 2018 AND 2019.
WHO WOULD EVER TRUST THESE
PEOPLE?
WAS NOT SO SHOCKING TONIGHT IS
AMERICANS, THEY HAVE NOT HAD
ENOUGH OF THIS.
THEY ARE SEEN THROUGH THIS
COMPLETELY.
LOOK AT THIS NEW POLL.
A DOUBLE JUDGE IT SWING.
OPPOSITION FOR IMPEACHMENT IS
NOW UP A WHOPPING 11 POINTS.
MARQUETTE UNIVERSITY POLLS SHOW
THAT IMPEACHMENT HAS DROPPED IN
THE GREAT STATE OF WISCONSIN.
POLITICAL POLLS SHOW THAT VOTERS
SUPPORT FOR IMPEACHMENT IS
DECLINING NATIONWIDE.
NOW, THERE ARE 3:30 MILLION
AMERICANS